this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace a lot of people want to know
how they can train their biceps their
lats their traps if they have no
equipment for the sake of argument we're
talking no dumbbells
no barbell
no pull-up bar even
and we're even gonna rule out things
like bags because most people have
access to a backpack or even a carrier
bag they can fill with heavy stuff and
curl
however that's not in the spirit of this
video today we're talking about how you
can train with nothing is it possible to
get your pool workout in using only your
body weight
[Music]
this might seem like a very strange
hypothetical question but it's something
I know a lot of people want to know I
know this because it's one of the most
popular articles on my blog and because
a lot of people are searching for it and
there is something nice about knowing
that you can train your entire body with
just your body if you're in a small
hotel room if you're traveling if you're
out and about and you have access to
nothing and knowing this stuff can be
useful for someone who say only trains
with yoga which doesn't involve much
pulling at all or someone who does a lot
of calisthenics consisting primarily of
just push-ups and squats because that's
a lot of what people do when they start
out calisthenics so yeah some of these
movies are going to look pretty odd
gonna look like a scene from The Exodus
some of the time we're going to see if
we can train the full body with just
body weight
okay it's raining not the best luck but
the Stray must go on I'm going to start
by talking a bit about the things you
might commonly see on videos like this
I'm talking in particular about a
movement called the half curl or the
elbow curl it's sometimes called this is
something that sometimes gets
recommended as a way to train your
biceps with purely body weight but it
sucks basically what you're doing is
lying on the floor with your knees
forwards and then pinning your forearm
underneath your legs you're then going
to use this as an anchor and pivot at
the elbow in order to curl up your upper
body towards your knees this is okay in
theory yes we're isolating the bicep yes
you're providing some resistance in the
form of your own body weight however it
looks ridiculous it feels extremely
awkward to perform and it kind of hurts
as well
Plus in reality the amount of resistance
you're getting from your upper body here
not great so yeah I don't massively rate
the half curl or the elbow curl even
though it is I suppose a legitimate
option
maybe I was a little bit too harsh on
the elbow half curls it's actually all
right I did feel a bit of a burn to be
honest all of this stuff is pretty weird
it's just not ideal
the other more common suggestion and
something that has a little bit more
legs to it is dynamic self-resistance
dynamic self-resistance basically means
providing your own resistance pushing
and pulling at the same time in order to
make a regular movement more difficult
this can work it all depends on what
you're doing so I've seen some people do
it with their leg crossed on their lap
sitting on a bench curling the lower
portion of their leg past the knee their
Shin essentially again this is Mega
awkward and the amount of extra
resistance you're providing by having
the weight of your leg is pretty minor
so again I don't really recommend it
what works a little bit better then is
just to provide resistance with your own
arm like so
you can push down
with the arm that's not working and then
you try and curl with the arm that you
are trying to Target
do some on the other side
now of course this works in theory I
personally find it to be a little bit
awkward I prefer to do a hammer grip so
I keep my fist like so and then provide
the resistance by pushing down on it
that feels a little bit less
uncomfortable to me you can do it in
front of the body but realistically it's
not going to build a ton of max strength
now overcoming isometrics that's where
you're pushing or pulling against an
immovable Force you know trying to curl
a railing or something that can be
really good for building max strength
because you're essentially giving your
max effort it's like a one rep maximum
problem is here because we're providing
the resistance ourselves you kind of
have these override mechanisms you're
always going to give yourself a little
bit of extra help at the same time the
awkward angle means that it's kind of
tiring kind of achy it probably can be
done but I don't love it sorry Charles
Atlas I don't think it's a great option
but it's better than nothing for sure
what I would say is if it's hypertrophy
and mass you're interested in then maybe
focus more on metabolic stress that
means maintaining the time under tension
maybe with shorter ring changes of
motion and just getting a pump
again it's not perfect
but better than nothing but I'm going to
talk about a couple more options for
self-resistance the first is to use a
towel you're going to lie on your back
and then Loop the towel over your feet
then you're going to pull your feet
towards you and then pull against your
feet as you push with your legs away so
you're providing the resistance with
your own legs now I did say I wasn't
going to rely on any external tools even
bags and things like that however I
think we can make an exception here
because you know you can use clothes if
you don't have a towel everybody's got
clothes right I can't remember why I saw
this idea I didn't make it up but it's a
cool option if you want to more
effectively provide self-resistance this
is probably the best option and again
you can use a hammer curl a neutral grip
or a supinated grip to slightly alter
the exercise as well one I did come up
with is essentially hugging your own
legs so what you're going to do is
you're going to sit on the floor so that
your legs are bent in front of you and
then you're going to wrap your arms
around them you can wrap them around the
inside or around the whole leg and then
you're going to squeeze your legs
towards you as hard as you can what
you're going to find is that this
doesn't hurt your legs because you know
you're not squeeze that hard at this
angle but it allows you to use a
isometric contraction a Max effort
isometric contraction which is more
useful for building max strength
actually another one you can do is
simply to curl your own arm like this
and just pull actually probably slightly
easier it does the same thing here the
resistances caused by your own stiffness
your own body and you can use this
maximum effort for a set amount of time
at the same time this position is very
similar to a choke hold
if you're a wrestler a fighter and you
want to make sure you can pin someone
and keep them there and not get gassed
out quickly this is a great option and
one final option for the biceps is
straight arm training because that means
things like pseudo planche push-ups
pseudo Financial lean means things like
tuck planche hold in other words you're
locking your arms out leaning your
weight slightly forward so that you're
engaging the shoulders and then holding
yourself in that position obviously the
planche works too if you're badass
enough to be able to do that but
basically what you're doing here is not
training the biceps so much as the
biceps tendons as you lean forwards with
your arms in that locked out position
you're going to be placing a lot of
strain a lot of resistance on the
tendons this is great for strengthening
the elbows and it can prevent injury
that might be caused by movements like
the deadlift so this is a great Plus for
my functional performance standpoint but
at the same time you're also going to
find that your biceps actually do grow
from this as you strengthen that tendon
and as you flood the area with blood
this is one of the reasons often cited
as to why gymnasts have such massive
biceps and such massive arms I always
took that with a grain of salt because
you know gymnasts do do a lot of
chin-ups they do do a lot of tricep work
etc however having started incorporating
the plants training myself and easing up
slightly on curls and things I found
that my biceps actually got bigger not
smaller so I think this is a way to
build bigger biceps as well as more
functional ones so that's the biceps
sorted got a few options there to both
focus on hypertrophy and strength and
strength endurance well what about the
back well we're going to focus a bit
here on the traps and on the lats
starting with the lats something that's
surprisingly effective for the lats is
the LaLanne push-up here's where you're
extending your arms over your head and
then you're performing push-ups like
that you can do this on your knees if
you find that difficult but the reason
this works is because not only are you
pushing through your shoulders but
you're actually pulling in order to
perform this movement essentially an
overhead pull again it's not perfect
there's a short range of motion there
are many other factors that mean you're
not going to exhaust the lats but it is
better than nothing better than a kick
in the teeth it's a good way to get a
little bit of training for that you can
use Ab roll out this is again using
equipment you could maybe use something
like a cloth to slide across the floor
form that towel exercise with the legs a
little bit more like a row rather than
like a curl if you want to focus on the
lats that way again that's probably the
best example that I can think of
you can also perform crawls while you're
reaching further ahead and then pulling
with your hands and actually crawling
uphill is a great way to do this so if
you don't have equipment but you do have
a bit of uneven ground that certainly
works and if you want to go really nuts
you can even not involve your legs so
you're dragging your legs behind you
like a zombie like I said some pretty
weird and out there looking moves here
but hey if it gets the job done and that
brings me finally onto the traps now you
have a video coming up on the Trap soon
so I'm not going to go into lots of
depth here but suffice to say that video
does allow the use of equipment so
there's definitely some stuff to say
here nevertheless one option for
training the traps specifically the
middle traps is to perform a bodyweight
reverse fly here you're essentially
going to lie on the ground and then
using your elbows you're going to fly
backwards that means bring the elbows
down in order to push your torso upwards
your legs should be flat on the ground
what you really want to focus on here is
squeezing the shoulder blades behind you
bringing them back and together and this
is going to place their emphasis nicely
on those middle traps of course for the
app traps the yolk that so many people
are interested in something you can do
actually is handstand push-ups and this
is surprisingly effective because if
you're doing your handstands correctly
you should be pushing through the ground
something I don't do particularly well I
strung to lock my arms out at the top of
the handstand without falling over but
if you get into that position then you
are actually also training your traps
because if you think about it it's a
shrug so your arms are overhead and then
you're shrugging to push even further up
so you can do this against a wall you
can do as a static hole so you can do
handstand push-ups against the wall or
you can even try freestanding handstand
push-ups and the great thing about
freestanding ones is that in order to
get your arms above your head you also
actually do utilize the traps a little
bit in bringing those arms back in that
position so there you go you're getting
additional work for the traps there
so realistically if that was your pool
day if that was all you did that
wouldn't be a fantastic workout let's
not kid ourselves but it would certainly
be better than nothing you'd get an all
right burn on your biceps you would be
engaging the traps and the lats a little
bit to help improve your posture and
things and it could balance out a
workout that was otherwise very
preoccupied with things like push-ups
which a lot of calisthenics workouts are
point is you can train your whole body
with just your body it's not ideal it's
not perfect but you can do it and hey
it's better than a kicking the teeth I
hope you found something in this video
useful or at least interesting if you
did then please leave a like and share
it around that helps me out immensely
let me know in the comments down below
if I missed any strategies you use for
training your biceps lats and traps but
remember the rule is no equipment
whatsoever maybe a towel or some clothes
if we want to push the boat out if
you're looking for an Innovative and
resourceful training program that you
can use to train your entire body using
minimal equipment then you might enjoy
my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 that comes with
over two hours of instructional video as
well as an 80 plus page ebook that looks
at performance across the board not just
building muscles to look good but
improving your performance things like
rotation strength grip strength straight
arm strength single leg strength all the
stuff that's normally missing even brain
functions so yeah check out in the
description if you're interested I'll
leave a link down below either way guys
thank you so much for watching this one
and I'll see you next time
bye for now
if you're looking for ways to do more
with less then you should check out
Squarespace today's sponsor Squarespace
is a website building platform that
makes it extremely easy for anyone to
create a high professional and
customizable website you start off by
choosing from one of many many templates
and from there you can customize your
website to your heart's desire and
create something as elaborate or as
simple as you like many of the top
brands in the world use Squarespace
because there's such a plethora of
features but at the same time it's also
perfect if you're starting out with your
first website just as a hobby because
it's so easy to jump into some examples
of some of the top end features include
the ability to earn revenue for example
through members only gated content
creating content is easy thanks to the
advanced publishing tools you can
schedule posts you can save drafts do
whatever you need to there's member
management you can track statistics and
see where your audience is coming from
you can integrate your social media and
have your various social channels
display right on your website there's an
advanced Suite of e-commerce tools if
you want to sell products from your
website as well it can enhance all of
these features even further thanks to a
huge number of different plugins for
example if you want to add Inventory
management or track shipping or handle
tax reconciliation and filing all these
things can be done through the use of
third-party plugins which greatly expand
the power of Squarespace even further if
you want to give it a try yourself then
head over to squarespace.com and when
you're ready to take the plunge use the
link in the description down below and
the code bioneer to get 10 off of your
first domain or website Squarespace is a
truly fantastic tool that levels the
playing field and ensures that everyone
can have a presence online thanks again
for watching this one guys thanks to
Squarespace for sponsoring
bye for now
[Music]